certains l'appellent le scandale de
l'air contaminé la présence importante
d'amiante dans les locaux de
l'université de jussieu à paris a pris
un tour nouveau deux victimes sont en
effet déposé plainte contre x pour
empoisonnement à ce jour 21 cas de
maladie ont été déclarés dans le
personnel de ce campus dont un
enseignant chercheur qui a donc décidé
de porter plainte
reportage olivier caroff gilles dollars
je respire de la maire de puiseaux
acceptent les résultats aujourd'hui
résultat une une plaque pleurales qui a
été dans quelques mois ce maître de
conférence et chercheur en physique de
jussieu fêtera ses trente ans de maison
mais en attendant il porte plainte
contre x son état de santé lui a été
caché pendant plusieurs années une
maladie professionnelle due à l'amiante
encore présente dans la plupart des
locaux jamais détectées par les services
médicaux de jussieu et dont il n'a eu
connaissance qu'en mai dernier dans le
cabinet d'un médecin indépendant
il a consulté une radio ancien qui date
de 80 de manille mais sur cette radio 82
déjà on voit une zone suspecte aurait dû
alerter la médecine préventive et au
processus scanner et cetera aurait dû
mettre a dû être mis en vente
on nous a menti en nous vend depuis géré
depuis 1975 quand ce problème a été
pierre reconnue bien établie la
présidence de paris si son université
évoque simplement une malchance du
professeur dans l'autre universités du
campus paris 7 certaines maladies liées
à l'amiante ont aussi été détectés mais
on continue à faire confiance au service
médical il est tout à fait conscient de
la difficulté que mars est personnelle
et il s'est engagé auprès de nous à ce
que tous les examens douteux par exemple
soir un feu jussieu compte dix mille
employés
les deux plaintes déposées ce matin
pourraient bien être les premières d'une
longue série